الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا اعدتها الى
القرن التاسع عشر حيث لا كهرباء ولا خدمات
تتوقفوا الحياه تماما بعد ان استهدف
الروسو البنيه التحتيه للطاقه نحن الان في
مركز مدينه لايف حيث كل شيء كان يعمل على
مدار الساعه والان كما تشاهدون ظلام دامس
توقفت عربات الترماي في الطريق بسبب
انقطاع التيار في المدينه لا محاله تجاريه
او محلات بقاله يمكننا ان نقول انه لا
حياه في المدينه التي تتعرض للقصف بشكل
يومي المواطنون يعانون من انعدام المياه
والتدفئه في درجات حراره دون الصفر يلجاون
الى وسائل تقليديه للطهي والتدفئه ان وجدت
والكثيرون فضلا نزح اكثر من 70% من
المواطنين غادروا المدينه كما تعاني
للمدينه من ضغط على جميع الجبهات لتوفير
الخدمات في مثل هذه الظروف هنا الجيش يخوض
حرب والاطباء يخوضون حروبهم وعمال
ومهندسون الكهرباء والاتصالات والشرطه
الجميع في حاله حرب لقناتي العربيه والحدث
حذيفي عادل ميلايف